[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
albert breer senior nfl reporter lead
content strategist for the monday
morning quarterback he joins us what do
you make of that story that mac jones
was going to be available for us today
and then we were told he can't
he's talking to a bunch of teams
i think the niners have them right where
they want him um
you know kyle's been reluctant to share
information with even people in the
building
i mean i can tell you that for a fact
dan and part of you know his process and
i think this is smart
um you know when they went through
january and february and kyla signed out
five coaches and a bunch of scouts to
to look at the the five first-round
quarterbacks was that kyle
didn't share his opinion on the
quarterbacks with any of those guys
because he didn't want them to be
affected by what his opinion was you
know like that they would think okay
i gotta think like kyle so i'm just
gonna agree with whatever he thinks so
you know kyle's kept his um his cards
close to the vest
through this process and um you know i
can tell you that that at both ohio
state and north dakota state um you know
for those second pro days for justin
fields and trey
lance the niners had a good amount of of
control to the point where their
quarterbacks coach rick
rich gangarillo was running the latter
part of both of those workouts and so
um yeah i think mac jones is the leader
in the clubhouse when they made the
trade
on march 29th but you know part of the
process for them was
let's see going through a full process
if either of the other two
who are more physically talented can
catch up to them
and you know the fact that they have mac
jones in the dark now three days out
doesn't really surprise me because of
the way they've handled this whole
process but do you think they made that
deal initially a month ago
without knowing who they were going to
take at the number three pick overall
well i i think kyle has an idea of
had an idea of what he was going to do
at the time um
whether enough has happened since then
to move him off of that
i i don't know um and i can't tell you
for sure that
that it was mack jones i'm just reading
tea leaves and what other people
who know this stuff really well you know
think um that i've talked to over the
course of the last month
um so do i think he had a strong idea of
of what he wanted to do when they made
the trade yeah i think kyle had a strong
idea of what he wanted to do but again
like
you know i've got pretty good evidence
that he hasn't shared it with a lot of
people
um and he wanted to have like an open
real process and when john lynch pulled
that trade off you know when they when
they make the deal
with chris greer and the miami dolphins
to go and get the third pick
you know i know part of the logic for
them was we want to be able to do
everything out in the open
we want to be able to set up a second
pro day for trey lance set up a second
pro day for justin fields
and go through all the zoom meetings and
all the different
you know machinations that you go
through with any prospect without having
to hide our intentions
and so you know i i just i sort of look
at this dan as
they knew they were taking would it be
worth going through all this
when everybody has a pretty good idea of
who the first two quarterbacks to go are
going to be
well the only thing and i'll go back to
what a source told me when they made
this deal
and that was that kyle liked mac jones
someone or someone's in their draft room
in the organization yeah we're trying to
convince them of trey lance
so here we are a month later and that
information has resurfaced
as if it's new information and it's not
yeah and trey lance like
i'll tell you this dan i mean you know i
make phone calls the
the like in the summer to kind of try to
figure out who the next set of
quarterbacks are going to be because at
that point like
you know a lot of teams like have gone
through all right our initial draft
meetings here are players we have to
watch
and when i did that with trey lance last
summer and this is before we had any
idea they were going to move off of
jimmy garoppolo trade up any of that
more than one team pointed out to me
he's an ideal
scheme fit for kyle shanahan now there's
a lot you got to wrap your head around
with trey lance
um i i would argue that the the
difference in competition between north
dakota state and the teams they play
might be larger
than the difference in competition
between alabama and the teams they play
um they beat the crap out of everybody
you know what i mean like
so trey lance wasn't in a lot of
critical situations he wasn't playing
for behind a lot he didn't throw the
ball a lot
you just you didn't see him in a lot of
the situations you want to see him
um you know coming into the nfl so
like i think part of this for the niners
is you know here in mack jones we see
somebody
who's shown us a lot of what we want to
see and then over here we've got trey
lance who's a really good
schematic fit for what we want to do and
can bring a lot of things to the table
that'll really open up kyle shanahan's
offense
we need to decide if we can get him
there with the other stuff
and to trey lance's credit like my
understanding is like he's come across
as
very very football smart in all of his
meetings which i know
is going to appeal to kyle shanahan and
the niners
we're talking albert breer a senior nfl
reporter and
of course works for the monday morning
quarterback um
you know trying to handicap all of this
and with these quarterbacks
you know and i always say you know my
logic philosophy is get
your quarterback not a quarterback and a
lot of times these gm's will say we got
to get a quarterback not
your quarterback if i said you had to
bet on
one of these not working out in the nfl
justin fields trey lance mack jones zach
wilson trevor lawrence
who would you pick i think trey lance is
the iffiest um
just because i i think it's the biggest
projection
um and the hit could be really big too
you know so
if you hit on him like i mean like
and i think the best con for him is josh
allen that's the one i hear over and
over and over again
trevor lawrence is a generational
prospect i think he's separate from the
group
i mean zack wilson i think the majority
of teams have him number two but i've
talked to some teams that have justin
fields number two
so um i like i don't know about zach
wilson
yeah i mean i know that he had a a very
good year
and he can roll left and throw right out
of pro day and throw it 50 yards but
i don't know and he's going to the jets
i mean you know how this winning and
losing is systemic
and i wonder about that when you put him
in a situation like that
trey lance could end up going to a you
know
a good team so much this is situational
right dan yes
i mean like if you want to bet on you
know
zack wilson with the jets or trey lance
with the niners
regardless of who they are as players
who are you betting i'm betting on trey
lance
because he's going because he's going to
be throwing to debo samuel
and brandon nyuk and george kittle yes
he's got trent williams blocking for him
and he has the best running game in the
league and a really really good defense
and they don't have to ask the world of
him
other than that you know like
i mean but so much of this is
situational there are so few
quarterbacks i think that come into the
league
and andrew luck i think is a good
example of it but there are so few
quarterbacks that come into the league
that can actually overcome bad
circumstances when they're young players
you know we talk about patrick mahomes
and i'm not saying patrick wouldn't have
made it otherwise
but look at his situation he was dropped
into
a team that was you know had a coach
who'd been building there for five years
a guy who is one of the best play
callers and quarterback developers
of of the gen of our generation right
andy reid throwing a tyree kill and
travis kelsey
he's got pro bowl level tackles and eric
fisher and mitch schwartz
he comes into the league a kid he gets
drafted with um
and kareem hunt wins the rushing title i
mean it's
there's just i think so i i think
sometimes we look at the quarterbacks
and we say
like okay like this guy's gonna be
counted on to change everything for this
franchise
when really whether or not they make it
rides a whole lot more
on what situation they're being dropped
i said earlier
if mahomes goes to the jets he's a
curiosity like we go boy that guy looks
like he has talent but
they're not a very good team or if he
was in jacksonville
you know to start we would look at him
as a curiosity we wouldn't say
he's the future of the sport and i think
he got into the right situation
and one or two of these quarterbacks are
going to get in the right situation
you know if justin fields goes to new
england or you know somebody goes to
atlanta here
uh you know they they might be in a
better situation than zach wilson and
trevor lawrence
uh speaking of atlanta this julio jones
information is starting to sort of
trickle out that
maybe he's on the block um how up for
grabs do you think is julio jones
it depends on what the falcons are
offered um but is he a second round pick
i mean i think for a first round pick
they'd move them you know and i think
they could agree to a deal this week
like i know like logistically they
couldn't execute it
until june 1st you know i i think if
somebody came along with the first round
pick now
you know like there's not a lot of
precedent for a deal like that like and
you know you have to make sure okay like
like
is like is julio gonna get hurt in the
spring like there's stuff like that that
can happen
but i mean it's not all that different
than you know the
the lions and the rams agreeing to the
matthew stafford deal in january and
then executing in march right
but but do you trade julio jones if
you're going to take kyle pitts
i think the my guess of right now would
be the falcons are going to take kyle
pitts
and i think if they had their druthers
they would keep
julio jones and throw kyle pits into an
offense with julio and calvin ridley and
three first-round picks in the offensive
line
yeah and and and matt ryan who like i
we're talking about matt ryan like he's
45 years old like he's still just 35.
he's got a few good years left
um but their cap situation is just it's
such a mess stan
that they have to do something i mean as
of today right now
they don't have enough room to sign
their draft class and they've already
mortgaged contracts for matt ryan for
jake matthews and for dion jones
and so something's got to give here and
i mean for terry fontenot and arthur
smith the new guys in charge there
really a big piece of this
is balancing mortgaging another contract
and julio's contract's a big one
mortgaging another contract versus
maybe just getting that contract off the
books
and then getting another player in
either this year or next year
who's going to be cost controlled for
the next four years which can really
help you from a cap standpoint
people try to
tell you what the patriots might be
doing or could be doing and it's all
speculation
because they never let any information
out but you're boston based
uh do you have any idea what bill
belichick
is capable of doing in the first round
so
like they've explored um they've made
the exploratory phone calls about going
up into the top ten
and um you know i know they've talked to
atlanta they've talked to carolina
um and and look like i don't want to
make a like that big a deal out of that
because these things happen this time of
year you know
and i don't think they're down the road
with any of those teams quite yet at
least to my knowledge
um but i i do think they're in sort of a
similar spot to where they were
in 2012 and if you remember they made
this they made it to the super bowl in
11 but their defense was really
it was a mess and that was the year if
you remember they had gronkowski
and hernandez and i think brady either
won the mvp or had an mvp type of season
um but they were playing julian edelman
on defense you know
and so if you if you go back and you
look at that year then everybody's
bill trey's down trades down trades down
he traded up twice that year
traded up for dante hightower and traded
up for chandler jones to try and fix
their defense both those guys were hits
you know a couple years later the
defense is completely fixed so i think
you know if you look at the quarterback
position i'd sort of line it up like
that
now like how do they value justin fields
i don't know if they value him enough to
make the
sort of move that it would take to go up
to four to get him
um but if he starts to slide that seven
eight
nine range now i think we might be
talking about something so
you know i i like where i think the
rubber could hit the road there
they've got relationships with miami
obviously at number six i think if pitts
and chase are off the board
miami might consider moving down they've
got you know i mean obviously detroit's
there and matt patricia's in the
building in new england he knows the
detroit
people the the lions are looking to
trade down
and then carolina has a director of
player personnel and pat stewart
who used to work in new england who has
all kinds of relationships in the
patriots building so
i look at that sort of alley of picks
there in 678 where if a quarterback they
like and
i think they've got some interest in
fields were to fall in that range you
know
maybe they might look at the idea of
going up do you want to get in on our uh
julian edelman bet sure paulie give uh
albert the bet
albert since you're a boston guy you'll
like this i made the bet that uh julian
edelman will
attempt to play professional football
for the buccaneers next year
instead of just going flat retirement
attempt to
and at stake is a pie to the face
uh the steaks oh so i gotta take a pie
to the face if i'm wrong
well are you you want to be in with
paulie and say that edelman
will at least attempt to play for the
buccaneers i'm gonna say he won't
okay all right he's bone on bone guys
i don't know i can't see it like who
knows i mean maybe he decides with six
games left he wants to do it and
i know he's got aspirations in hollywood
and everything else and maybe those
don't work out and he decides i gotta go
be a football player again like i don't
know
i just i'm not counting on it but is
gronk playing this year
yeah okay yeah and that was the one for
me so like i i
dan like you're right like because i i i
look back like
i was in the super bowl standing next to
rob gronk
after the patriots beat the rams i was
standing next to rob gronkowski in that
locker room after the super bowl
and you i was convinced he was done and
he retired shortly thereafter and i
thought
this guy's just had it with football and
a year later he's coming back so i guess
anything's possible
enjoy this week albert always appreciate
you joining us and uh
thank you we'll talk to you soon thanks
dan